[ __ ] got me [ __ ] hurt [ __ ]
hurts like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like I
told shrinking oh my god
okay oh oh [ __ ] if I can love Jean
Osmond it's great you know I've done
this a million times five seasons I
still get nervous every before every
single ups I don't know why you think it
like you would get over that but you
don't that is Matthew I love it you know
I'm like an improv king I'm an improv
King okay
[ __ ] there on those okay there we go
you sit here and we go in press space to
start holy [ __ ] do I look good [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Dex [ __ ] [ __ ] on a brick
tinder I'm running I'm running oh my oh
my missus scary good thing I got my
lucky green t-shirt on and my great hair
easy everybody tries their damnedest to
beat me but nobody can you know it mess
with the best you die like the rest
that's all I gotta say baby holy Toledo
is there you go
hey baby what
well look at that folks we made it hey
I'm locked I came back [ __ ] guys that
someone actually [ __ ] okay I'm excited
oh it's a [ __ ] like a scream no tasks
laughs whoa this make me shoot something
okay holy [ __ ]
you know know that I travel fog lights
is it's [ __ ] like cocaine hey dad get
in the [ __ ] bad Cowie
perfect so make me kill some over the
game yeah yeah with these people
you got that right I'm stronger than all
of them Oh Jemmy yeah hey take your I
love jelly our stay same area both of
them you know they're both great
I got a [ __ ] a good thank you sir
idea Shack I don't know can you help me
can you have me sign first to talk about
10 years I can laws talking the sliding
oak alley you look pretty scary or that
reflection like that
what time is that sticker for the box
they're looking to take a shower I'll
talk my Stacy is that's cheating on
Juliet I'm talking to a chick on hang it
sorry I'm not really listening [ __ ]
likes they say I think I'm showering
okay you understand or anything you
shower over there right
[Music]
thinkin if I could talk like I get it
your captive but like you know like you
if your stuffed animal will talk to you
like I don't need to talk to you oh [ __ ]
can we [ __ ] floating how are your
second scaring me Jesus Christ getting
up there Kelly yeah so doc can I bite
not getting scary all right let's do
this
I'm excited and happy all right oh oh
it's [ __ ] dark in here no I forgot
kiss me now
I already did this okay thank you I
guess that's our advice over these boxes
oh they move those boxes that's what
happened okay interesting
hey it's like I'm scary
how can I agree a spare key in the safe
down into Laura's office okay spot on
that producer
every nut copper ajar for that crack
close this whoa
that is me right yeah it's up yep
what is that acquisitions if all the
pasture security team funds from
personal exam Sephora collection no ID
badge the new groom coded [ __ ] I think
I picture this should I write this down
I guess I should write this down into a
picture one eight four six five what
okay you know that's doable let's see
what's in here though robbery situation
one thing I'm loose in the building so
I'm bad Harper all used to the grinder
to be suspended the [ __ ] is offended say
a Oasis arrival
I hear that [ __ ] muttering is that him
what is that marketing department now
there's more
[ __ ] come on
they don't back
that they were
security oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] sprinting what is that dolorous
there's a key in here holy [ __ ]
okay Sparky Sparky [ __ ] is that
there's no transference okay nothing in
here nothing in here
ooh we're supposed public's need to any
assets not listed you drink trick to the
grinder foreign bodies were star
positions breeding program what the [ __ ]
was a grinder I'm kissing Suki
holy [ __ ] is that scary
directive [ __ ] scary
this is a spare key uh he thought he's
out there
[ __ ] docker it's [ __ ] scary
where's the Sparky he said dude penis
spirit okay oh [ __ ] did they [ __ ] say
there's a spare key in here okay whoa
Kawai hey baby shank through the screen
a lot as well wait did they send in a
[ __ ] spare key in here
where the spare key be my leaf [ __ ]
spare key
I hate that noise
I'm stuck I don't know where the spare
key is feel like I'm pretty thorough
usually - that's just a sick [ __ ]
this very keen to Boras office
what the [ __ ] where they let me Amy in
this room I can't touch anything
it's like in the plant or something it's
somewhere it's shipped here the trash
can anything in here they said spare key
card
okay what does it say the new green room
code then I suppose [ __ ] right
Deborah yes statement [ __ ]
so hazing
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I'm going back to my spot [ __ ]
can I just [ __ ] go to sleep
[Music]